we are now joined by the head coach of
the oregon ducks
dana altman as promised coach thank you
so much i know you're a busy man got a
lot going on thanks for joining us here
on the rich eisen show this is dan helly
glad to be a part of it dan well
congratulations
once again to making it to the sweet 16.
this is uh
nothing new for you you have been here
before you've been at the elite eight
you've been in the final four
what's different about this team
well we've got unique pieces this year
dan
we're starting you know five guys that
are all
six five six six and you know we can
really spread teams out
um we have had some difficulties garden
inside which will create big problems
with usc with their size and
created problems last night with iowa
but
this team you know can get it going
offensively when they do
they're they're tough to guard we've got
all five guys that start can shoot the
three
all five can put it on the floor and and
make plays
so we're a unique team offensively
and defensively we try to change things
up a lot
so that people can't take advantage of
of their size against us but
been a fun group to work with we've gone
through
injuries we've gone through the covid uh
we lost our
postman who was a great player in
polydante the sixth game of the year to
acl
injury which made us go small and
the guys adjusted well well
the number that really stood out uh to
me was not the number everybody was
talking about when you guys beat iowa
and put 95 points up on the board and 56
in the first half it was a 25 assists
the ball movement you you must have been
elated
i i know you guys have done that
throughout the season but you've never
put
95 points up on a board and i i don't
know that you've had 25 assists in a
game maybe you have but you look
fantastic dan you're right i
i was really proud of the guys the ball
movement last night was
the best we've had we were beating him
off penetration the help would come we'd
kick it out
uh we we hit 11 threes because we took
good threes
and the ball movement uh was really good
and
that's something that's critical to our
success i keep
emphasizing it to the guys that you know
when we've been successful in ball games
it's because
of the ball movement uh the shot
selection
you know we we are a good defensive team
not a great defensive team but a good
defensive team and
we've just got to make sure that we move
the ball and
we've got five guys who are averaging
the double figures
so we've got to pick out the weak
defender and and try to take advantage
of it
what are the numbers you talk about the
the ball movement
uh yeah 25 assists you mentioned the 11
threes you also had 10 dunks in the game
what are you going to be putting up
there on the whiteboard in your pregame
speech to the guys
if we do this this and this against usc
then then we're gonna take this game
well the first thing is we gotta rebound
the ball
with their size you know they're a very
good rebounding team and and so
you know we can't be giving up second
and third shots
they played very well against kansas
last night if you caught that game and
we're going to have to make sure that we
don't give them any second shots
when we lost to them in la they got off
to a great start hitting threes
so defending the three down will be
really important to us
um you know so they've got a great
balance
inside out obviously the mobley brothers
inside
give them a one-two punch inside their
guards can all shoot the three
so very tough defensive assignment but
we just can't let him go crazy from
three
uh like they did in the first ball so
we had you originally scheduled for a
little bit earlier in the show but you
were on the phone with a relatively
important person that you were talking
to right before this
absolutely no chris vortey our off guard
is up for the very prestigious uh
jerry west award he's one of the five
finalists
and um you know obviously i'm very
biased but
he's my guy and uh you know i'm i'm sure
glad for him and he's honored that he's
been considered for the award because
all five of the guys are very deserving
but again
he's my guy and i'm i'm hoping that he
wins that award uh
peyton prichard who was our point guard
last year
won the bob cousy award and uh you know
this is
a very prestigious award for off guards
and we're sure hoping
that chris wins
dan helly filling in for rich eisen on
the rich eisen show talking to dana
altman head coach
at oregon you mentioned chris duarte uh
23 points
last night listen you've been in oregon
for 11 seasons had tremendous success
five sweet six teams you've been to a
couple of elite eights the final four
where does chris rank among the players
that you've coached at oregon
well he's he's right at the top i mean
we've been very fortunate uh you go all
the way
back devote joseph was a pac-10 player
that was all all-conference
dylan brooks jordan bell chris boucher
you know peyton pritchard we've we've
had some really good ones
and uh you know chris was runner-up
player of the year
in the coaches vote uh to mobley
but he was the ap player of the year in
the pac-12
he's played through injury his
efficiency numbers dan are
off the charities 53 from the field 42
from uh three and and eighty percent
from the line
uh rebounds five rebounds a game he was
on the alt defensive
team you know so he's an all-around very
good player
uh he was a junior college all-american
and his two years with us we'll be
the pac-12 champs both years you know
and
hopefully we can continue playing we got
a tough one against usc
on sunday and and hopefully we can move
on to the
elite eight you got to keep everybody
focused
you got to keep these guys loose what
are you doing for the next few days when
you guys aren't on the practice court
it's it's obviously a different
situation this year in the tournament
what are you doing to keep these guys
entertained
and how do you keep from over scheduling
that's what i always wanted as a head
coach
you don't want to do too much but you
want to keep them active and busy right
damn this is unique situation here you
know we've got
five days uh before we play now and uh
we are set here on the 14th floor of the
marriott and
and we're not able to go anywhere um so
it is very different for our guys
and different for our coaching staff
we've never had anything usually you
have a
a team hotel and you got all the parents
in and
you know the band the cheerleaders
everybody's around you got fans and
uh it's kind of a festive atmosphere but
now
it's just real quiet and everybody has
their own floor
they've got all 16 teams here in the
marriott and
you know everybody's just waiting to
play on on saturday and sunday
so it's going to be a long four or five
days for everybody
but i you know we're we're going to the
zoo today
uh then to try to do something different
and
you know just try to get outside a
little bit and
we didn't do much for practice we we
played yesterday and
we don't play again till sunday so he
even after today we'll have four days to
prepare for usc
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here